[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and it is that
time of year where we've got a new
version of android and all the fun stuff
that comes with it now we usually have a
name for the version as well it's
usually named after a suite like
marshmallow or kitkat or oreo jelly bean
something like that uh i guess that got
a little too crazy because now we're
just on straight numbers so
android 12. but this this feels like
easily the biggest android redesigned to
happen since maybe the beginning like i
feel like i've seen a lot of visual
changes to android over the years but
this is truly the biggest one because
visually everything is different
literally everything i feel like i was
actually kind of surprised when i saw
all these big changes because android's
been you know maturing and you know
doing little refinements and subtle
tweaks over the years but i'm on beta 2
of android 12 here on this pixel 5 and
both under the hood and on the surface
there's a lot to take in so i'm going to
go through my top five biggest changes
slash biggest new features in order of
importance so of course the timeline for
when you get this update is going to
depend on what phone you have some of
you with pixels will get this update
earlier than others but when you do
finally get android 12 you should be
prepared you should know what to expect
so this video is for you
okay so number five
this is a more of a back end thing
actually but android is just going to be
getting even smoother and faster
and i've talked about this in the past
you want to see them get as fast and
smooth as possible close the gap with
ios and so i always welcome this stuff
so in android 12 google streamlined the
cpu time for core system services by 22
that's a pretty big jump that means no
matter what hardware you're on whether
you have an older chip or a snapdragon 8
as long as it's running android 12
things should feel a bit smoother less
jitter less jank and stutter again this
is beta 2 on my pixel but i'm already
liking a lot of the new animations and
the overall smoothness of things when
flipping through the ui and you know
there's no limit to how much
optimization is a good thing but with
this software combined with the rumor
sort of floating around that google may
be designing their own silicon for the
first time on this next pixel
that combined could be
pretty sweet as far as overall
experience i don't want to get my hopes
up too high but just want to give that a
shout out now number four these i think
might fly under the radar a little bit
because not everybody uses these but
widgets there are new widgets so there's
a new widget selector and there's a new
set of all completely redesigned widgets
in android 12. now this is the beta 2
right now so i just have the new widget
picker but i love this just mainly
because for every app that has any
widgets it now will show you in line
every single widget that that app gives
you how it'll look before you even add
it to the home screen so there's no
guessing when you start adding things
and that's very intuitive again you
probably only have to set up your
widgets occasionally maybe once in a
while but that's great now the newly
redesigned widgets themselves aren't in
this software yet but i have some screen
recordings straight from google
themselves that really show what some of
these new widgets are about and they are
really really different they're really
different this new clock is a very
different look like it's a little more
abstract with the date rotating around
instead of a second hand it's a lot it's
definitely a lot and so theoretically
google is going to finish updating all
of their stock app widgets so that
developers can see what they can do with
this new functionality and to just get
the whole look together
so far i'm excited just to see what it
looks like when it all comes together so
then number three
privacy
now you might not think of google and
privacy in the same sentence very often
but seriously there is a commendable
amount of privacy controls here you have
a lot more control in your hands and i
think that's going to be the key word
the control so first of all they added
these indicators to the top corner for
when your camera or microphone are being
accessed by an app they're both green
and they're in the top right corner this
is something ios has been doing for a
while that we were asking for although
it might have been cool if they were
different colors like in ios but it's a
little bigger and you get a little icon
the point is now you immediately know if
an app is using your camera or mic and
if you want to change that access it's
easy you swipe down from the top and tap
that indicator to go straight into the
permissions of whatever app just
triggered it then you can take away that
access then you also have a couple
optional quick setting buttons you can
add they're not there by default but if
you want to add them you can have a
quick setting toggle to immediately turn
off camera access or microphone access
to everything so if you're about to do
something or say something for some
reason you don't want any apps on your
phone to have that access to the camera
or mic you just flip the switch and it
turns it off and so no app will get
accessed until you enable that again so
all that's nice for peace of mind that's
that's another level above and beyond
what we see on the iphone so that's cool
then if all of that wasn't enough
there's also now a privacy dashboard
inside the settings and that privacy
dashboard will literally show you for
your location or camera or microphone or
anything else an actual timeline laid
out of every single app that has access
that sensor or that information and when
it did it so that'll make it much easier
to see exactly what's going on if
there's any rogue apps doing crazy
things in the background killing your
battery pinging your location all the
time you better believe it'll show up
here and you can just get rid of it
straight away and then lastly when apps
ask for your location for the first time
there's a new toggle that will let you
select giving them your precise location
or just giving them your approximate
location just the neighborhood you're in
that's pretty useful so for maps for
example i'm of course going to give it
my precise location because i want to
use it for navigation and it just needs
to know where i am but hey for any other
apps that don't need to know all that
maybe my weather app or a news app i
still want local news and local weather
but i can choose approximate locations
so they can't do any weird ad tracking
with my exact latitude and longitude
that's pretty sweet okay so number two
these new quick settings so
it's obviously aesthetically very
different
it might even be the most aesthetically
like defining feature of android 12 like
every preview you see definitely shows
this stuff
but there's also some new functionality
too so you pull down from the top and
you've got these huge toggles that are
separated from the notifications area
you can see this to me is interesting
because i remember so much previous
google talk about getting rid of wasted
space and minimizing the blank empty
space but now there's this big clear
separation here and actually think it's
nice then when you pull down again you
get this huge brightness slider at the
very top and these gigantic tiles for
whenever you want a quick setting it's
of course still customizable like i
showed so you can add or remove toggles
but there's also a setting shortcut and
a power menu shortcut underneath it all
the internet selector ui is a little bit
different too so when you have a sim
card in your phone it's going to show
you both wi-fi networks and your cell
connection in one place which is nice i
think it consolidates two buttons into
one
and of course you'll also still have
ongoing notifications that show up at
the top too like if you're playing music
or something that's unchanged but it's
going to be at the top with the quick
settings instead of mixed in with the
rest of the notifications
generally though
i think i like this new look it's
definitely like it's very different and
it takes some getting used to but the
toggles being way bigger obviously take
up more space but also they're huge
touch targets now they're hard to miss
you get the mic access and the camera
access tiles and the screen recording
tile is great and so that brings us to
number one which has just got to be
the whole new look the new aesthetic
material you just the whole new design
here so if you don't remember material
design
is a sort of guideline that google's
been using since 2014 to help developers
make their apps look like they were made
for android so they fit into the look
material u with this new aesthetic is a
sort of an evolution of that that's a
bit more personal as you can tell by the
name so obviously things look very
different there's the big buttons we
talked about the big volume control
slider big brightness slider at the top
huge quick settings toggles and even all
the text through all the menus and
settings is also now larger there's a
new power button menu which puts these
three huge buttons in a triangle for
some reason and there's also a new
charging animation when you plug in your
phone sort of sweeps up from the bottom
from the charge port and there's even
more bouncy and friendly looking
animations around all this bigger text
and this is still in an early beta like
i said so i'm sure stuff will keep
getting added over time like the screen
on and off animation that they showed on
stage at i o where it would like emanate
out of the power button but probably the
most noteworthy thing here for material
u
is the color and style selections that
you can make to match it to basically a
theme that you make for your device so
it's not exactly a whole theme engine
but now in settings there's a wallpaper
and style section where you can change
your wallpaper you can change the grid
size you can change the style and accent
colors of your buttons and your icon
shapes and all of that and then material
u will take the color of your wallpaper
and choose a lock screen clock and quick
settings accent colors to match what it
thinks will look good with that
wallpaper so with this yellow wallpaper
for example as soon as you set it it
gave me this dark yellow clock for
contrast and it seems like it typically
sticks with lighter kind of pastely
versions of the primary color or
complementary color of the wallpaper so
since it's a totally yellow wallpaper i
got yellow quick settings but when i
switch to this mostly blue wallpaper you
can see everything adjust here and it's
been pretty smart about contrast and
everything so far to keep things
readable
but yeah this is another feature that's
going to continue to evolve into the
final version of android 12 when it
comes out later this year but it's
already a pretty cool touch just making
the whole device feel like one cohesive
experience change your wallpaper change
your life that's what i always say um
now this material use stuff is just on
pixel for now something to keep in mind
and this whole android 12 experience
it's just the way google is making it on
their phone which is the pixel so when
you get it on your phone if it's a
oneplus if it's a different
samsung look it might have a different
aesthetic to it but you'll see a lot of
the same features and general themes but
yeah let me know what you think are you
a fan of this new change it's a pretty
big one i feel like it it takes some
getting used to like when i saw it on
video i wasn't as convinced i would like
it but after using i've gotten used to
it now with a day of the beta and i feel
like i'll continue to like it more and
more as i use it
but yeah that's it also i've done an
interview with google's ceo sundar
pachai so if you haven't watched that
video already i'll link it below like
button and we also did we also did a
deep dive
on all this material you stuff on
episode 65 of the waveform podcast which
is now on youtube so i'll leave a link
to the waveform podcast youtube channel
below as well and big shout out to the
sponsor of this video expressvpn because
if you care about the privacy features
that i just showed you in the latest
version of android well then you'll
probably also want a vpn because even if
you are on this latest version every
time you search or watch something or
tweet or really do anything from your
phone it's pretty common for third
parties to snoop on that which is not
cool so i protect my data with
expressvpn so one of the most tracked
data points out there is your ip address
and so that can be used to identify you
and your location but with expressvpn my
connection is rerouted through an
encrypted server making my ip address
much more difficult for third parties to
track on any of my devices but then on
top of that because the server can be
somewhere else you can unlock thousands
of new shows that are not available in
your region because you can convince
whoever service you're using that you're
in a different region based on what the
server is so i've been watching plenty
of top gear it's not available on the us
netflix but it's only available on
netflix uk so with expressvpn it's easy
i literally just switch my location to
the uk and i can watch it so protect
your data
and get more content with expressvpn
it's that simple you can visit the link
below you can go to expressvpn.commkbhd
to get three months for free either way
that's been it thanks for watching catch
you guys in the next one
peace